good morning on CBS is warning Saturday
co-host Michelle Miller and we're in the
Toyota greenroom with author and
journalist Keith O'Brien now we've
learned all about famous pilots like
Amelia Earhart and Charles Lindbergh but
most know little or nothing at all about
the competitive sport of airplane racing
in the 20s and the 30s now in Keith's
new book fly girls how five during women
to fight all odds and made a V a shin
history he weaves together the
narratives of five women who flew
competitively and whose stories have
been mostly left out of the history book
so we welcome Keith O'Brien thanks so
much for having I I'm really thrilled to
talk about this because you know as we
were still talking about Amelia Earhart
and and it's you well point out she was
not the first nor was she in some
circles and some opinions the best or
the most the most talented in her
efforts tell me who these women were so
you know you're right you know when we
think about women today in aviation in
the 1920s and 30s we think about one
woman Amelia Earhart as if she was all
alone like she was doing it all by
herself but when you go back and you and
you and you live in microfilm and you
immerse yourself in this time again you
see that she was flying with this
squadron of other women and they came
from all kinds of backgrounds you know
some came from money some didn't some
more educated some weren't you know
their fathers were were lawyers and and
Wall Street traders but also laborers
and farmers but they all shared this
passion they wanted to fly and and
truthfully to put it more bluntly they
wanted to choose their own path because
you to be a woman a young woman in 1927
and to choose to fly was to choose one
of the most radical paths of all yeah I
mean you were labeled certain things you
were cast out of proper society and as
you said many of this will these women
were staunchly concerned about making it
on their own because they wanted to be
independent we should name them you have
two roots a
wheeze and a Florence that's right yeah
so so the main characters the book in
addition Amelia Earhart
Ruth Nichols who was one of Amelia's
biggest rivals she was raised in New
York City in Westchester County Louise
Thaden who came from Bentonville
Arkansas in Wichita Kansas Ruth's elder
who was from Alabama and Florence
Klingensmith who was from rural
Minnesota such a range here how did they
form this squadron because they were
friends were they not and rivals they
were yes especially Ruth Nichols Amelia
Earhart and Louise Thaden they were the
core of this group they were they were
friends and rivals you know they all
merged organically you know in the late
1920s air racing became one of the most
popular sports in America I imagine
primitive airfields literally air strips
where a half-million people would gather
over a course of a weekend not to see
air shows like we think of them today
but air racing these were extremely
dangerous and extremely thrilling this
is the time of Charles Lindbergh this is
the time of daring flights and these
women who were aviators wanted in they
wanted to be part of this sport and yet
they were kept out in many instances
from competing and from actually
showcasing what they could do and in
some cases what they could do sometimes
better than men
what were those barriers there were so
many barriers for these women you know
in the beginning they didn't let him
race at all in 1928 these women you know
led by Louise Thaden and Amelia Earhart
they lobbied to be part of the Air Races
the men finally in 1929 allow them to
race but they put all kinds of
restrictions on them instead of just
racing from Los Angeles to Cleveland
like the men would do the air race
organizers forced the women literally
force them to stop in 15 different towns
because they didn't believe they had the
quote-unquote stamina to make it across
the country in one hop or two hops
that's just the beginning of it you know
there were there were rules at the time
by the Department of Commerce which was
which was what predated the FAA
Department of Commerce had rules that
that suggested women shouldn't fly when
they were menstruating these were the
times that these bold female aviators
lived in and they they refused to live
by those rules you know they pushed
their way into the races and ultimately
they would triumph was there one thing
that they did that helped them pierce
the veil I'm sure that Amelia Earhart's
efforts and really the publicity that
she garnered helped a lot of their
efforts but I mean what was it that
pierce the veil how did Earhart push
through well Earhart initially was a was
a social worker in Boston you know we
we've mythologized her to the point that
we've forgotten her beginnings and how
much she struggled she was a social
worker in Boston and and she was a pilot
as well
and in 1928 some wealthy men were
looking to put a woman across the ocean
you know they wanted to find the the
female Charles Lindbergh and so why did
she fit their mold
why was she okay as opposed to like a
Florence or Ruth you know what was it
about her that sort of put her into the
forefront it was a lot of luck there was
a there was a plane that had been
acquired for this historic flight and it
was it was a giant sea plane and it was
sitting in the water off the coast of
Boston and the harbor there and if you
were looking for a female aviator in
1928 in the city of Boston there was
really only one woman to call and that
was the social worker on Tyler Street
and so Amelia Earhart gets this call and
and she gets an offer to - not to fly
this plane and this is again an example
of the of the sexism that they faced at
the time they didn't offer her the
chance to fly the plane what was she
just supposed to stand there she would
look pretty she was gonna ride his cargo
she would and she knew it she knew it
was her term she when she made it across
the ocean flown by men in 1928 she
became a global star you know someone
who got her own book deal and someone
who went on tour but she knew you know -
her enduring credit that she had really
done nothing for that fame and and she
said you know I I was just a sack of
potatoes on this flight and you know in
the rest of her short life and
sadly it would be just another nine
years Emilia would do everything she
could to to prove that she could make it
in the sky and by extension that that
other women could to you know if a woman
could prove in 1928 that they could fly
that they could race that they could
race the men that they could win that
was that was proof that they could do
anything because that stage in the late
1920s early 1930s the stage in the air
was the most glorious stage of all and
it was the stage of I guess equalizing
it was a great equalizer because if you
could withstand the dangers of aviation
then up in the sky what could you do on
the ground absolutely and and to be even
more blunt about it you know these women
had to overcome more than the men
because not only did they have to face
the same dangers the same risks of
crashing the same risks of disappearing
over the ocean they had to fight through
harassment and demeaning comments just
to get a pilot's license just to just to
just to be on an airfield before they
had proven themselves and so if you were
a woman in 1928 1929 who not only flew
in the races but even just got a pilot's
license you had proven that you were of
strong character and clearly an
excellent aviator because you had flown
through so much already I had grown up
hearing about another another aviator
Bessie Coleman the first
african-american woman to have a pilot's
license I would imagine the barriers for
black women not only just black women
but all blacks who were trying to you
know enter this field was stifling what
was it like for someone like Bessie
because you did research on even her and
the reason you said she wasn't in the
book was because she died before this
era of women came along correct so my
narrative takes place between 1927 and
1937 specifically you know this
narratives about women fighting for the
right to fly and the right to compete in
the air races sadly you know Bessie
Coleman predates that she she was a true
pioneer you
she she earns her pilot's license and is
flying in the early 1920s at a time when
you find almost no women in the sky and
Bessie sadly crashes and dies in a what
was known as a Jenny a JN for every
primitive biplane in 1926 in April of
1926 Bessie Coleman dies in front of a
crowd for reasons unknown you know when
a plane crashed in those times there was
no there was no black box there was no
way to determine what had happened all
too often these things just did happen
and and so Bessie dies about a year and
a half before before this narrative
really begins yeah I I would I would
enter into part of the discussion
because there was such a tendency for
people not wanting these people to be
involved it there was sometimes sabotage
involved in some of these instances
where people there their planes would
miraculously not be able to fly because
they were tampered with what those are
some of the stories that I heard what
did you rate with your research provide
sure so in its it's a great point in
1929 when women first earned the right
to race in that first all-female air
race where the men make them stop
fifteen times across the country they're
no they're not just one stop into that
race when suddenly the women are
reporting that their planes seem to have
been tampered with mechanical problem
yeah Ruth elder who was one of the most
famous of them all at that time you know
had gas gasoline poured in her oil tank
instead of in her gas tank other women
reported that the brace wires on their
their wings which is the wires that
connected them to the to the fuselage
added extra support snapped as if they
had been cut with pliers you know there
were investigations you know none of it
was ever proven but these women you know
believed that their their planes had
been tampered with
but whether that happened or not you
know whether men on the on the ground in
San Bernardino California were tampering
with and trying to sabotage their planes
you I think what was almost sort of
worse than what was clearly happening
was the way they were covered by the
newspapers you know
when when a man made a daring flight you
know he was a hero
he was an air man he was he was a
gladiator
you know the press went out of their way
to to call these women anything but an
aviator you know they were lady birds
they were sweethearts of the air you
know they were powder puff girls and
outer puff girls you know that term that
you hear today you know powder puff yeah
this actually is is born in 1929 when
these women fly across the country the
race begins its official title as the
the national women's air race and the
press by day to start pulling at the
powder puff Derby and where does powder
puff fit into the world of aviation sure
so you know in 1920 it doesn't but in
1929
you know powder puff was was a common it
was a little thing that you used to feel
like wow yeah by your makeup and there
it was a very popular item at the time
and there were powder puff salons and
you know powder puff ads in the
newspapers and so they called him the
powder puff girls it really bothered
them you know Amelia Earhart said at one
point you know would it you know would
it kill them just to call us pilots
mm-hmm the death of so many of these
pilots as we said it was a dangerous
field how did that play out when it
happened to a man who crashed versus a
woman and and and what is it that you
want people really to glean from this
book moving forward
sure so when a man crashed and died as
inevitably they did in these races they
were often hailed as a hero sometimes
they were giving grand tributes right
there on the airfield that weekend with
21-gun salutes and flybys and his ashes
scattered from a plane you know well
everyone you know bowed their heads you
know when oh when a woman died in these
races as as sadly would happen and would
and does happen to one of the main
characters of fly girls she she doesn't
even get the most basic human respect
it's infuriating
at times these women gave everything to
do the thing they loved and we've
forgotten them it just feels
wrong and with fly girls I hope that we
give them the recognition that they so
deserve and I hope too that we show that
you know Amelia Earhart wasn't alone you
know this wasn't just some kind of
one-off accidental hero you know she
stood shoulder to shoulder with other
heroes and hopefully with this book
we've written him back into the story is
that what sparked the fire in you to
write this book I can tell you exactly
where I was when I knew that I had
something here I was deep in a newspaper
archive and I stumbled upon this Air
Race where one of these women died and
and how it was treated by the press was
stunning and insulting and and yes that
that that is where it began for me I
tell you I am thinking about the women
of the mercury 13 in Space Flight
and how they had such hopes and how they
fought to enter the space race at a time
when we were just entering it and then
to have their hopes dashed over and over
again you see so few women in this field
how can this make a difference well I
hope it shows to to anyone who reads it
you know man or woman boy or girl know
that anything is possible you know that
if you work hard if you persevere you
can do anything and you know these women
showed that and and they the ones who
lived into their into into old age into
the 1960s and 70s they continue to
advocate for young girls to to join to
join them in the sky the book is called
fly girls how five daring women defied
all odds and made aviation history Keith
O'Brien we thank you for writing it we
thank you for visiting us here in the
Toyota Green Room at the CBS News
broadcast Michelle for having me